good morning members
good morning members of the public
you're all very welcome to today's baby
district council plan committee
of the 5th of may may first of all
remind you of some of the domestic
arrangements
please ensure that microphones and
cameras are turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
if you wish
that if you wish to speak or a point of
order
or point a declaration or interest or
requesting the german
please use the hands up on the function
tab
members are reminded they should not
have alternative communication lines
open other teams chats
and that if you're contacted by a third
party during an application you should
bring this
to the legal advisor's attention
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
if members do lose connection to the
meeting that they must contact the
member support office
officer you have the numbers um
already as soon as possible we will be
using modern.gov to conduct
all electronic votes during this meeting
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewings
the hold of the meeting will be recorded
except whether
confidential or exempt items if you make
a representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented
to be and recorded by entering this
meeting
as a speaker you are also consenting to
being recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those same
recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public and press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
i'd like to introduce the following
officers
the area plan and manager mark russell
planning lawyer in depress
governance officer robert carmichael
case
officer linda bacon and we have a new
young case officer mr michael brooker
i think it's his first meeting with us
he's very welcome this morning you'll
meet him a bit later can i now move to
the agenda please
the first item is substitutes and
apologies
i think we're all present is that
correct robert
just for just for confirmation i'll do a
quick roll call just so that we can
confirm all members are here and can
speak
so if you could respond with your
presence this morning counselor
suitaires
i'm president thank you councillor
melanie barrett
yes present counselor david busby yeah
here
counselor john hinton president castle
lee jameson
yeah prism council mary mclaren
president
council adrian osborne present council
allison owen
present pastor lee parker president and
councillor stephen plum
president thank you chair we are all
here this morning just to note um we
also have
the board member of councillor mick
fraser i don't believe we have
any other ward members that are not
already on the committee
okay thank you very much
uh right i'll just point out at this
point um
i'll carry on for the moment uh to
receive decorations
uh for interest for members is there any
to declare
no that's none right we'll move to item
three
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 24th
of march i don't believe we've received
them
have we
robert sorry chair i was just unmuting
um we have got them chair they are in
the table papers
um if members do need a few minutes to
just review them ahead of
um this then i would suggest members
take a short break if needed to review
them if they
weren't right they weren't sent
separately they're in the table papers
because there was nothing else in the
table of papers no that's that's correct
yeah
right yeah
members um can i ask if there's any
points of accuracy
right because you've all seen them
because they were sent in the table
papers i saw them there but i
didn't usually they're separate as well
but they're not
um right can i ask for a proposal please
nobody wants to prepare councillor
parker
yeah i have to propose thank you uh
councillor osborne
i will chair if no one else right
counselor plumb
will second them yes i will thank you
very much
uh mary mccallum's
counselor no they're all gone
right okay so it's been proposed and
seconded there's no
uh points of accuracy um so
we'll now go to the electronic vote
um i'll ask robert to take us through
that please
thank you chair if members could please
go to the modern.gov app
and go to today's agenda they will see
in the top right hand corner the plus
sign
if you click on that bring down the
subsection on attendance and voting
if you click on that will take you to
the voting page and the vote will show
in progress in the light blue color
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and the result of the vote is
10 votes for with one abstention so that
is carried
thank you very much all right and we'll
move on um to see if there's
any notification of petitions robert
none have been received here thank you
very much
uh item number five site inspections
um officers are there any site
inspection requests
um chair there was some correspondence
from joe hobbs at one of her sites
that's the only one aware of
right um robert have you got anything to
say on the
site inspections at the moment
currently we have the update from the
council's tactical management team
which deals with all of the health and
safety aspects
of officers and councillors to ensure
that mem
all officers and employees and members
are protected
during the pandemic we have the update
that
site visits as they usually were will
continue and restart
from the 21st of june i believe when
the next um
roadmap roadmap yes the next part of the
roadmap is reached
um and in line with that chair so um i
can't really give you more than that and
that's that's the update lovely so i'll
come to the members of other any site
inspection request bearing in mind what
you've just heard
no it looks like oh sorry councillor
busby
yeah i'd like to call one for a site
visit for cop dock
it's uh quite a large development up to
170 houses
um there are a number of issues and
it's not necessarily saying whether it
should or shouldn't go ahead but if it
goes ahead there should be
certain conditions attached to it one of
the significant things is the access
onto the old london road
which uh highways haven't at this point
i don't think have
responded to but i think members need to
see the site
and let's hope that we can get highways
to respond
by the 21st of june so that then we'll
go out with more information
uh yes um so you're asking for that
after the 21st of june
yeah whenever we can get out that's
right yeah um
members uh i think sometimes
we had one of these i think um really at
this point i think all we need to do
robert is say there's a second
to have a site inspection and then that
can just be
sorted out in due course robert i'll
bring you in next
robert sorry i have to unmute another
microphone as i'm live streaming this
morning
um yes yeah that's fine um if it's
possible council busby could we have the
reference number
um for our records it's dc slash
21 slash 0207
3. right
um and so yes chair the procedure here
would normally be
um that as council buzzbreed has
requested it
as a proposal we would then ask for a
second and then we would have to go to a
vote on that point to
review it well i will second it with
pleasure
um so that we can go to oh sorry there's
some hands up um
well well i've seconded it now uh are
the hands up for that or did you wish to
speak on this plan
on this um site inspection uh
counselor i was born your hand is still
up so you wanted to speak on the
well yes i'd i was going to second that
mr sherman but
uh i agree with david uh i think it's
it's essential on some of these
larger um applications that we do get a
site visit
it's got um you know it
is it's got everything that you need to
see on the site
and that is where we need to come from
thank you
okay thank you right robert would you
like to take us to the electronic vote
we we can't do this by calling no
no that's fine [ __ ] i've just set it up
and just to confirm
that the wording for this vote will be
that members conduct a site visit
of application dc2102073 in cop dock and
just confirm that as the right reference
number councillor busby
oh 2073 yeah yeah fantastic
so um members i will now start the vote
on that so if you had could
please go to the modern.gov app
and go to the agenda for today go to the
plus sign in the top right hand corner
members will then be asked members will
then be shown the
attendance and voting tab and it will
take you to the vote that's in progress
that's shown in a light blue color under
site inspections
oh i think i hit the wrong things take
me right out wait a minute
um
if you need to chair i can take your
vote verbally
yeah i've got to log back in i'll do
that
anyway um
oh yes
okay
come on
um oh it's gone all potty for the minute
let me
let me clear this and start again
because i need to have it work and don't
i
uh while you're doing that peter mark um
parish council meeting last night the
the count parish council expressed
a desire to have a meeting with the
planning officer
and i know that's happened on a number
of occasions whether
that could take place would would you be
able to this application yes
for this application yes uh yeah we do
we do do those um
i'll speak to joe hobbs about that
no for some reason i've lost it all
together
um so i'll have to give it to you
because otherwise
um i'm in favor of the site inspection
thank you then chair so with your vote
as well that makes a unanimous vote
for the proposal so assignment in site
visit will be conducted of the
application
um just bear with me i'll see if i can
get reconnected
all right uh yeah password i'm gonna do
now
mr chairman yes it's coming through now
sorry yes somebody was trying to speak
yeah it's uh sadr and
um mr chairman um i've just um i hope
we're not duplicating but
i i noticed that was the site visit from
joe hobbs earlier on was mentioned this
isn't the same application as david has
been speaking about is that
i don't know i have to ask robert
plus it was my understanding it is rob
it's um
it's joe hobbs the case officer
so so uh david's i think i'm i've logged
back in robert
sorry mark yes counselor it's it's
unless i've got something uh
terribly wrong it's the same case it's
the joe hopps case for the
170 houses 170 odd um
at cocktail washbrook it's the same one
right good well we've agreed it so
that's good okay let's move on
if there's no other um requests at the
moment
so we'll move on to item
number six which is plan an application
to be determined by the committee
members i intend to bring forward 6b
which is on page 21 first
that's in sudbury because one of our
members
counselor airs has a
[Music]
dentist appointment and as we all know
it's very difficult to get any
appointments
you can't really not attend them so
she may have to leave before we finish
this but um
she will drop out gracefully if that's
the case
but we'll continue now and hopefully
we'll get through while she's still
present
thank you um i'll now ask linda baker to
take us through this
thank you mr chairman and good morning
members um i hope you can
see on screen and uh hear me also
good so um this is an application that's
before you because
it's a council application baby district
council is both the applicant and the
owner
this aerial image shows the site located
to the north of
newton road bottom left is bellevue
house
bellevue road is located to the west
it runs uphill before turning through 90
degrees into burrows peace road where
access is then provided to the rear of
the site
at this point immediately to the
left west here is the former leonard
hospital building which is a locally
listed building and has been converted
into residential use
this is the site location plan in the
wider context so bellevue road
running up to burroughs peace road and
access is across the front of this
building
and into the back here in terms of
site constraints there are none that
really affect the proposal although
there are two
tpou trees on the site frontage and
they're not actually shown on this image
this site layout plan is is not that
clear but it does show
the main building and the detached
garage to the
rear vehicular access is shown from the
north
through this point
the property has been in long-standing
use as a large house in multiple
occupation
or large hmo it currently has nine
bedrooms and was previously
leased to suffolk county council who
used it as an hmo
for more than 20 years they used it from
april 1998 to march 2020
and since then it's reverted back to use
by baber
as an hmo homeless unit
the application proposal is twofold
permission is
sought to convert the existing detached
garage into an office
where staff can meet with residents of
the lees in a confidential environment
together with a small rear extension to
the main building
along with external alterations so as to
increase the number of bedrooms from
nine to twelve this slide before you
shows the external alterations thatched
there's no
change to the front south or east side
elevations
the north elevation shows the garage
door
this was the garage so the garage door
being replaced with infill brickwork and
a window and doorway being inserted
there's a modest single-story rear
extension at the rear
shown here and the size and position
of some of the existing windows and
doors are to be altered as shown on the
west side elevation
here so we're looking at a couple of
doors being blocked up so
pedestrian door into the garage being
blocked as are a couple of doors
in the main building here and here and a
couple of the windows are being resized
and slightly repositioned
also so this is the existing ground
floor plan it currently provides for
four bedrooms and a kitchen
this is the proposed ground floor
there's a single storey extension just
here
so it's it's a fairly modest extension
and further subdivisions within the
floor plan allow for two additional
bedrooms to be created on the ground
floor
this is the existing first floor plan
and shows five existing bedrooms
and this is the proposed first floor
with one additional bedroom
so across both floors uh three
additional bedroom spaces will be
created
this is the proposed office created
within the existing garage
so the existing up and over garage door
will be replaced with brick and fill
and a pedestrian door and a window
this landscape plan a little unclear but
it shows the
the main building in this area and this
is the garage
the main point really was the
landscaping is that the existing
driveway
to the north is just being enlarged in
this area to provide additional parking
for two cars looking at um
photos of the site so this is the access
to it
along burrough's piece at the rear and
the access actually passes in front of
this building
and then turns right just before the
hedge
so this is a view down the driveway
towards
the building and the garage and rear of
the building is just coming into view
this is the garage where the up and over
door is to be replaced
and the small rear extension
is just in this area
wider view of the same so garage to be
altered and converted into an office and
a small infill extension
at the back that's the reverse view back
up the driveway
back onto burrows peace road
closer version of the same and this is
just an image of the front elevation
onto newton road this is the elevation
itself is
unaltered there are some alterations to
paving
there is no existing vehicular access
here there are some steep steps
and this view is taken from the top of
the first set of steps
so the application proposes dedicated
office space
to serve the existing hmo homeless unit
which is to be upgraded to provide three
additional bedrooms and accessible
facilities
which will add to the district's
temporary housing facilities compliant
with our policy cs18
there are no external immunity impacts
and there are no adverse highway safety
impacts
it's therefore recommended that planning
permission is granted subject to the
suggested conditions
thank you thank you very much for that
i'll see if members have got any points
of clarification
just before i go to that i just
apologize to councillor mcfrazer i saw
your
note come up and but unfortunately i
didn't i wasn't aware that you needed to
get away
i had a request yesterday from
councillor ayers
and that's why we changed the procedure
round but hopefully we're not going to
be too long on these and we could get
there quite quickly for you
anyway members is there any points of
clarification
um that you would like to ask the
officer
uh yes there's councillor uh jameson
followed by councillor osborne uh yeah
thanks thank you chair i just wanted to
ask the um
bedrooms they gonna be reduced much in
size with the addition of the new
bedrooms
um there is some reduction in bedroom
size um
the existing rooms are reasonably large
so just showing there the ground floor
plan they are there are some large
bedrooms there and
there are some subdivisions for instance
that large bedroom to the front is being
subdivided to create too
so we're going to reduce doubles to
singles is that
looking at those those pitches is that
right or
um well there we it's possible that
could be the bedroom one could be
capable of taking a double whether these
are
for illustrative purposes or or could be
interchangeable depending on need but it
does show that
there are single beds on this image in
beds one two and three
um four also
and bedroom six uh is a double
bedroom five is a single
some of those single beds look as though
they could accommodate a double
yeah okay thanks councillor osborne
i thank you thank you um mr chairman i'm
just
uh clarifying the position of the u
trees which are covered by a tpo
um i might write and assuming that uh
minor works were carried out in 97 and
however these will not be
um dealt with in any other way as part
as part of the uh uh extensions or
um uh office build on on the garages am
i correct in that linda that's quite
correct the u trees are literally on the
site frontage onto newton road
and all of the works are the extension
is to the back here
and the garage is here so they are away
from the trees and the new trees aren't
proposed to be altered in any way
as part of this application thank you
councillor barrett
thank you chair um can i just clarify
that although there's going to be three
new bedrooms is there any
uh additional communal space um
uh bathrooms or or lounge area or
kitchen that's
um in this plan um
there there are communal space and
you've got
kitchen areas and each bedroom will have
a very small kitchenette also provided
there's shared laundry shower rooms
there's an additional bathroom
as part of the proposal so that's the
ground floor plan
and the first floor plan shows two
bedrooms
whereas i believe previously there was
one so there are additional
bathroom facilities and a shared kitchen
and laundry
okay thank you thank you i see no
other hands up so we'll move on
there's other points of clarification
thank you
uh we don't have any public speakers so
we'll now move into debate
councillors has decided to is the ward
member
that has decided um to remain as part of
the planning committee so she can take
part
as often as she wishes
all right members um
council aires would you like to start
it's your award
yes thank you very much chair um i would
just say that we
so need places for people who are
homeless
and these extra three rooms will be
absolutely ideal
and i would i would propose that we
accept is something we desperately need
very well laid out and to have another
space for the staff
and a place of privacy for the people to
be interviewed
um so i have no objections whatsoever
thank you
thank you councillor barrow you were
next i i'm aware that you've proposed
that uh councillor
um i'll get a seconder in a moment
counselor barrett oh you've gone cancer
osborne
yeah thank you uh mr chairman i
absolutely agree with
the councillors on this one it's a
necessity that
we really want and having an office for
staff to
actually meet with the uh um residents
is an ideal uh ideal situation and i
have no
no problems with with this i think it's
a it's a great innovation to uh
to the homeless uh uh problems that are
around
not so much probably in sudbury but in
the district itself so
uh i'm happy to second that as well all
right thank you very much
so i've had a second any other comments
members
no there's no hands up yes there is
counsellor busby
yesterday and i know it's not a
condition that we can apply to it but
i do think we ought to insist that the
trees and the wall the problems that
have been identified in the plan
are sorted out i mean i'd like to almost
put it on as a condition that they are
sorted out before this thing goes ahead
i think it's crazy that we should be
responsible for
a building that's or an area that's not
really
up to scratch um
linda can you help on this um
yes it comes from two comments that have
been received from
um neighboring properties and whilst
they don't object
they have raised some issues about
maintenance of
the boundary wall as well as landscaping
in the front
needs a little bit of attention so i did
put those comments
um to the weber officer uh who's dealing
with the application or has submitted
the application
and they have replied to say that the
wall will be inspected in the next
couple of weeks and they will get the
repairs carried out
and that secondly as part of the
refurbishment project
the front area will be improved the
landscaping will be
looked at and thinned out so they will
maintain the front garden
area better and inspect and repair the
wall as necessary
so they're taking responsibility for
repair on the walls because
with particularly with old properties
the years roll by
and whoever originally owned them nobody
wants to own them
if they're a great expense so i think um
this needs to be very clear i think
councillor busby is right
um we could add it as a note to the
um approval i i don't believe we can
impose it as a condition
but i'm happy to add an informative note
to that effect
yep i'll be happy with that counselor
busby yeah that's great thank you
good thank you very much uh will will
the proposal and secondary accept that
yes chair absolutely yeah i'm happy with
that
and it's good that good david has
mentioned that because the maintenance
of these properties
uh ones that could actually fall into
disrepair
it's nice to know that uh it's going to
be dealt with thank you
all right thank you um there's no other
hands up
so i'm assuming that everybody's spoken
who wishes to speak
so if that's the case then i'm going to
ask the
robert to read out the proposal
and then we'll go to the electronic vote
thank you chair before we just go to
that point i will just need to confirm
with um linda bacon and mr mark russell
the
um what the informative note will say so
that we can have that in our
um vote thank you
uh linda you know the site better than
me what what is the matter that the
applicant needs to attend to
um the side boundary wall on the
which way we ought to be on the the
western side
needs to be to be reviewed and
maintained
as necessary
so words the effect of the applicant is
um
the applicant is is reminded
um that the western boundary wall should
be
maintained in a satisfactory condition
something like that he said
uh yes safe and satisfactory for the
wall um but also that the
the front arc sorry the front garden
area
requires some maintenance yep okay good
okay robert uh not quite sure i'll just
need to um
ask him i'll just just go through that
just one more time so i can add that in
or if mark can send it to me whichever
one is easiest um i'll send it to you
rob's that then need to go to
before the vote or shall i do it um well
if you want we can do it two ways we can
either do it as i can put it in or i can
do it as read out by
um the area planning manager
okay on that yeah
mark can you read it out please okay so
so the sense of it is chair and i will
finesse the wording afterwards so that's
okay the sense of it is that the
applicant is asked
to keep the side boundary wall in
a state of good repair and safe and good
repair
and also to ensure that the front garden
is kept in a visually satisfactory
manner is that right linda is that the
issue there
uh yes i believe so yeah okay so that's
the sense of it rob and i will send you
a properly worded
um informative after committee if that's
all right chair
yes i'm sure the um the proposers and
second are quite happy with that
chair i think i think it ought to be a
bit more immediate than that i think
it's not just that they should keep it i
think it the
work should be carried out um
strongly advised do you want to say
strongly advised camps
uh councillor busby is that is that more
the uh the tone you're after strongly
advised
i mean we can't tell them to we're
asking them very nicely they wouldn't
mind
strongly values then the works are
carried out
in the short term to
remedy the issues of the wall and the
garden
or walls on the garden if there's more
than one
i don't think we should be too specific
about it we should make sure that the
whole site is up to scratch
mr chairman can i just make a comment
please yeah
i agree with everything that david said
here however i
i'd like it uh i'd like it noted that
the
the trees that have been uh with the
tpos
should be uh uh kept and maintained
uh as they are i don't i don't wish to
see
when they uh do improvements to the to
the front uh
area of the garden that uh they
somehow chop them down because they
believe they're
not in a good position so i i'd like uh
i'd like to be added that the trees
are kept as they should be well the
trees have tpos on them councillor i was
born
and they can't just cut them down they
can
cut them back for safety reasons or for
health reasons
of the tree um but they can't just come
in and cut them down so i don't think we
need to concern ourselves on that too
much because
that that that clause is already there
right do you want to come in
i agree with what you're saying mr mr
chairman but
you know as well as i do that trees have
been disappeared with tpos on it and
once that's happened nothing's actually
good yes but
that's usually comes into one of those
categories as to why it's happened but
anyway
robert can you help on this please
um just for uh um i think as we're sort
of getting into other points here
rather than um just do it as read out by
the
planning of um mr russ mark russell i'm
going to ask him just to write it out so
that we're all completely clear
on what we will be voting on um as other
points have been raised
don't miss it now mr yeah so we don't
want to make this any more complicated
than what it is but we do want the
walls repaired and safe and and the
garden maintained i think that
and quite strongly i think is the words
to use but
um mark have you got it so you can read
it out yes i'm just doing it now chair
do i understand that the third clause is
to relate to make sure you look after
the tpo treats as well is that what the
sense of that was
well i think that goes without saying
but there's no reason why that can't be
part of it
yes i would like to see that in there mr
chung please okay
you do you trees are they neighbouring
the site on the site linda
[Music]
you might want to change this a bit
bring this under a bit of
pressure right there you go that's come
up on rob i've sent it to you i can't
see the main chat so you'll have to
distribute that wording i can't get it
onto the chat
robert perhaps read it out and then
we'll know yes chair i'll do
i'll do that i'll copy and just put it
into members votes
so that they can read it there as well
for the sake of
completeness
right so um
the additional point as raised by mr
mark russell
um and by members is the wording
sorry i've got two computers i'll get to
the right one is that the applicant is
strongly advised
to ensure the boundary walls are
retained in a safe and satisfactory
manner
and to also ensure that the garden is
maintained in a visually satisfactory
manner
the applicant is also reminded that the
u trees on site on the site frontage
are tpo'ed and should be cared for
accordingly
excellent excellent good uh councillor
hinton i see your hands up
yes mr chairman we've been making a bit
of a meal out of this
but let's let's not forget that the
applicant is baba district council the
owner is labor district council and we
are baba district council leaders
so we should be able to tell baber
district council what to do in this
situation and not worry too much about
what
wording is put where well we've got the
word no
but your points are noted counselor
hinton
uh right members i'm now gonna ask
robert to
take us to the electronic vote
thank you chair so if members could
please go to the modern.gov app
and go to today's agenda and go to the
plus sign in the top right hand corner
their members will see the drop down and
subsection of attendance
voting and if you could please go click
on that and the vote will show at the
bottom of the page in a light blue color
you may need to scroll down to access it
yes you do right i mean
press this
conceal them
i'm just waiting on one more vote
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and i can confirm that the
motion was carried unanimously
well done thank you very much members
uh right we'll now move on to
6b
which sounds 6a yeah
which is on page 11 and that's hadley
and and
case officer michael booker
michael would you like just introduce
yourself and then if you'd like to
present the
um application if you turn your camera
turn your camera on so everybody can see
you at the start
thank you good morning members uh yeah
so i'm michael booker i'm a
case officer for this application and
this is my first committee so um
please bear with me and i'll just
share my screen now thank you
yes that's uh yes it's come up
can we hear you oh yeah can you uh yes
yes say and hear you that's fine
okay so this is um a reserve matters
application uh five station road for the
erection of
one dwelling um to assess the appearance
landscaping layout and scale
and an improved vehicle access um
and this application has been brought to
committee as the applicant is an
employee of the council
remembers a reminder this presentation
should be viewed in conjunction with the
committee report and not in isolation
okay so the site is outlined here in red
it's approximately 0.05 hectares in area
and the blue outline here is the
other land that's in under the
applicant's ownership
so this is um the location in hadley as
it's outlined by the red line here it's
situated just north of station road
which if you follow to the west will
lead you straight into hadley high
street here
and if you follow to the east it will
take you along to the a1071 towards
ipswich
it's located in a residential area with
houses of similar sizes and plot sizes
in the surrounding area
in terms of constraints the application
site isn't located within the
conservation area
but the conservation area is outlined in
purple here and as you can see is
located just north of the
conservation area um approximately about
80 meters to the
south east is a cluster of crater listed
buildings um
which is the granary and station yard
and the site also lies within
the built-up area boundary of hadley
so this is the site is existing and this
is the
entrance which will be a shared entrance
and the existing garage on site which
will be removed
um it'll be in a similar similar
location
um to the existing garage um but
situated slightly further
which i'll show you on the plans later
on
and um sorry and as you can see and the
existing house on site
is comprised of brickwork and cladding
and this is also the site from another
angle and as you can see there is a
two-story dwelling um
to the east of the site
um so this is to show the character of
the area as a as i mentioned it's um
primarily brickwork and cladding in the
area and it's situated
along a row of single story dwellings
which are also comprised of cladding and
brickwork with similar roof tiles as
well
and this is the views from the existing
access
um so this will be looking out onto on
towards the conservation area
and as you can see there's um a row of
terrace houses um
opposite the site which um just to give
you an idea of the character of the area
this
um varying styles and sizes
so this is the site layout plan
excuse me um apologies it hasn't come up
very well on the powerpoint here
um but this uh red dash line here is to
show the existing garage that's to be
removed
and um the proposed dwelling is to be
located in a similar location but
um slightly further away
from the existing house um there'll be
two parking spaces on site
which is in line with the suffolk county
council highways requirements
for a two bedroom dwelling um
in terms of landscaping though the
existing cherry tree on site is to be
removed
um and having a conversation with um the
council's agricultural officer and this
tree is not of any significant immunity
value so its removal is not opposed and
there's other
landscaping proposals such as um raised
planting and
planting of new trees along the boundary
here
which is to be controlled by a
landscaping condition
and the site has a large uh parking and
turning area here which is
sufficient for the two cars on site and
does not impede on the existing house
house parking or turning around which is
located here
um although it was considered under the
outlying permission um improved
vehicle access has been provided under
this application so will be considered
with a new drainage channel to prevent
surface water discharge onto the highway
and an improvement in the width of the
shared access
which is in line with the suffolk county
council highways dm01 specification
and this is the floor plan of the
proposed house
um it's approximately five and a half
meters wide by
12.5 metres in length um it's a two
bedroom dwelling
um with the entrance on the western
western elevation
uh there'll be a kitchen with a shared
living and dining area and a bathroom
here as well
and these are those elevations for the
house um so it'll be
uh brickwork and weatherboarding which
will um
uh match the existing house on site
which was on an earlier slide with
claypantiles as well the engine store is
on the west elevation which will face
onto the
um onto the side elevation of the
existing house as well
um and as i mentioned it's a single
story so it's not
consistent have any significant
residential immunity issues
um and the window on the rear of the
rear uh north facing elevation here
provides an approximate back-to-back
distance of about 25 meters to the
houses to the north um so no issues of
privacy are overlooking
um so the recommendation for this
application is for approval subject to
the conditions that are outlined within
the report
thank you remember
so you you have finished
mr booker oh guess how yeah yeah sorry
yeah
right perhaps you can remove the screen
of the sharon
oh yes it has helped uh we can see you
so that
i'll now see members are there any
points of clarification to mr booker
before we go into debate no we've got a
ward member
to come next no
no hands have gone up thank you thank
you mr booker but stay with us because
there
might be friends that we need to come
back to you about public speakers we
don't have any but i believe
councillor um michael fraser is with us
this morning
uh is that correct uh good morning
um councillor fraser how are
you have five minutes in which to
address the committee
um so over to you and then we'll see if
there's any questions
yeah uh yeah thank you mr chairman no
i've got no comments on this
um i was merely just here for observing
as it is my award
thank you okay good thank you very much
uh right members we can know uh
is there any questions sorry that you
wanted to put to uh councillor
um fraser i don't think there can be
no okay we're now going to debate
uh thank you mr brooker if you'd like to
turn your screen off for the moment but
stay with us in case you're needed
members who would like to start
no one's put their hands up so you're
all quite happy with it then
[Music]
um but if that's the case oh cancer
barrett
[Music]
um thank you chad um i
i think the the you know the um the
the lack of objection the um
the um acceptance my heritage
um uh
this there's very little that i can find
in here that wouldn't
meet with approval um and it seems
you know we are in want of single-story
dwellings that um
uh provide good access into town centers
because it's very
very uh close to the shops and the
schools and things like that
um so um perhaps i can
uh suggest that we approve this and
go to the vote thank you i'll serve the
second to councillor hinton
thank you mr chairman um yes i'll i'll
i will second it but i'd just like to
make a comment that's the
the property next door has undergone a
similar sort of metamorphosis
uh and i must have confessed that i'm
not particularly
enamored by the end gable approach of
the properties to the to the street
scene
uh it does rather look like a sort of
big sheds being erected in the garden of
the
of the bungalow and is a little bit out
of character um
but i can't see that there are any real
planning reasons why we should uh
refuse this especially as it has already
got outline commission
okay did you want the um
the case officer just to comment on what
you've said i can ask him counselor
hinton
um you you can ask him
right um case officer booker
did you want to just comment on on those
views that counselor hinton
has just mentioned although he's
reasonably happy he just wanted
a bit of clarification i suppose
um yes i'll share my screen again um it
was the the gable wasn't it on the
face on the street scene yeah um
let me just find the so um on uh this
picture here is sort of a similar
approach to this dwelling here that's
what it was um considered kind of a
direct design and
um when measuring it's about sort of 15
meters or so back from the highway
with uh there's a lot of hedgerows here
so it's not going to be particularly
visible either
right thank you hopefully that helps um
councilor hinton uh councillor busby
[Music]
yeah on the similar vein if you can go
back to the picture of the
sorry of the numbers
no the proposed development there aren't
many other it's the
it's the end view on but i'm looking
yeah it just looks as though the roof is
particularly high
um the one next door
[Music]
has a lower pitch to the roof it just
seems unnecessarily
tall um
so the the overall height was about five
five and a half meters which
is uh i believe it was close to um
like this house here it wasn't uh too
much of a difference
um okay but i just think if you look at
the one that's on the
bottom right the gray one in the middle
there that's has a has a lower pitch to
its roof yeah
i mean it's just a small point i mean i
don't uh
i'm quite happy with it i think but um
you know robert you wanted to come in
[Music]
thank you chair um i just wanted it
noted that council airs has left the
meeting
at 10 10 19 just so that everyone is
aware of that
thank you um
yes hinton um yes i think taking up
councillor busby's point if you look at
that uh
roof line and the next door property
it's about the same
height as the existing dwelling
but because it appears to be slightly
wider it does rather
mean that the pitch on it is slightly
shallower
i think the the one that we're
considering at the moment it seems to be
a narrower property and therefore the
pitch is that much steeper
and that's what gives the impression of
it being a lot higher
all right thank you hopefully that's
helpful members
uh any other comments
[Music]
robert your hands still up
[Music]
right now other comments then um it's
been proposed
and seconded to accept the officer's
recommendation i'll ask robert to read
it out
for us
so the recommendation for us is as laid
out in the table papers
sorry in the office recommendation
um with no additional conditions or
informative notes etc
so chair with your approval i will go to
the vote
so members if you could please go to
today's agenda
and go to the plus sign in the top right
hand corner members will then see a drop
down on the subsection on voting
attendance if you could please click on
that it will take you to the voting page
where the vote will be shown
in a light blue color it will be about
three quarters of the way down the page
thank you chair that all votes have now
been received minus councillor heirs who
left the meeting
so that is unanimously for oh
thank you very much well thank you then
uh officers and members we've come to
the end of today's meeting
um so just to point out that the next
scheduled meeting is down for wednesday
the 19th of may
at 9 30 and this will be held at
endeavour house
uh details will follow but members
perhaps should remain after they've
closed down
and you'll be updated on that thank you
so i'll wait until the live stream
is finished
you